voici le plus grand plateau de cinéma à
ciel ouvert d'europe
bienvenue à fort bravo un village
construit de toutes pièces pour le film
de sergio leone
il était une fois dans l'ouest
regardez c'est comme l'arizona où le
texas c'est exactement ce que cherche et
sergio leone c'est spectaculaire avec
toutes ces montagnes
et lorsque ce far west espagnol
n'accueille pas de tournage il est
ouvert aux visiteurs
l'occasion pour eux de revivre en direct
certaines grandes scènes des films de
l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a vraiment l'air réel on s'y croirait
c'est comme dans les films
situé dans le seul désert d'europe les
lions ont servi de décor au plus grandes
épopées hollywoodienne au total plus
d'une centaine de réalisateurs ont un
jour posé leur caméra ici est ce que
vous seriez me dire quel film a été
tourné ici c'est pas lawrence d'arabie
oui c'est lawrence d'arabie
lawrence d'arabie indiana jones ou
encore astérix et obélix ont par exemple
été filmée ici
et mon jeu passait à travers ces
l'arizona même l'australie et maintenant
on a un paysage africain un peu plus
loin l'afghanistan en fait si on a tous
les pays de la planète
comme à hollywood les noms des plus
grandes stars venues tourner ici sont
inscrits dans la rue
pour la municipalité l'impact économique
des tournages n'est pas négligeable
j'estime qu'une grande production qui
vient tourner ici almeria peut générer
en seulement une semaine entre 100000 et
150000 euros de bénéfice net par jour de
tournage pour almeria
ce fut le cas avec le film exodus
tourner dans ce décor de carton-pâte
ozer d'égypte antique
ses décors nous ont été données par la
production de ridley scott quand ils
sont venus tourner ici
et aujourd'hui encore il nous sert pour
de nombreux tournages par
thaïs est fixeuse son métier trouver des
lieux de tournage en fonction des
besoins des cinéastes
là on recherche une plaine désertique
donc ce lieu pourrait bien qu'on voie
après le tourisme l'industrie du cinéma
est ici la deuxième plus grande source
de revenus une superproduction rapporte
en moyenne 5 millions d'euros à la
région
[Musique]
on l'appelle el andaluz le train
d'allumer un vestige du siècle dernier
parfaitement restaurée
c'est un train historique
ces wagons accueillait même la famille
royale britannique quand elle partait en
vacances
à bord une trentaine de passagers
profitent d'un circuit unique cadix
séville grenade toute l'andalousie en
moins d'une semaine
en quelques jours de train nous allons
plus découvrir le sud de l'espagne que
si nous y avions pris une voiture et se
sent la fatigue de la conduite
dans land da luz le style belle époque
et respecté dans les moindres détails
j'ai toujours aimé les trains même petit
je jouais avec
j'aime le voyage regarder le paysage et
des petites gares typiquement espagnol
prochain arrêt ronda
perché au sommet d'impressionnantes
falaise
ronde dame est la porte d'entrée de la
route des villages blancs
arabe peignait les murs du village en
blanc parce que ça donnait beaucoup de
lumière à lure
c'est pour ça que les villages tout
autour de nous sont blancs
le célèbre pont de ronda relie la
vieille ville aux arènes
c'est la première qui fit bâtir en
espagne problème en ronde étant donné
que les ordres étaient toutes les places
et chagrine toujours car en
face aux montagnes de la sierra n'ya
hemingway orson welles ont trouvé
l'inspiration
aujourd'hui les voyageurs perpétue la
tradition
[Musique]
en fin de journée
landaluze repart
destination grenade
[Musique]
balayé par le blizzard voici
l'andalousie comme vous ne l'avez
peut-être jamais vu très loin des plages
des terres arides cette région abrite
aussi l'une des plus hautes chaînes de
montagnes d'europe la sierra nevada
là bas vous avez le mont mula scène qui
culmine à plus de 3400 mètres d'altitude
qu as tu aurais pu lutter chaque matin
il est le premier arpenter ces montagnes
des sommets qui par leur situation
géographique sont tout simplement unique
au monde ici vous pouvez parfaitement
venir ce qui est le matin et ensuite
prendre votre voiture et en une heure
une heure et demie eh bien vous êtes sur
la côte méditerranéenne et vous pouvez
vous baigner et pour cause derrière ces
montagnes se trouve la mer méditerranée
de quoi offrir aux skieurs un paysage à
couper le souffle
là bas vous pouvez voir les montagnes de
l'atlas au maroc en fait on voit toute
la côte africaine
si quelqu'un m'avait dit que je pouvais
skier ici je l'aurais pas cru
si versant nord la sierra nevada est une
station de ski côté sud la neige a
disparu sous cet immense forêt de sapins
se nichent certains des plus beaux
village d'andalousie un format qui a
fait il a fallu adapter tout le village
à la colline c'est pour ça que toutes
les maisons sont construites en escalier
à bout bionne ils ne sont qu'une poignée
d'habitants à vivre à flanc de colline
et ça c'est la vie en ville il ya du
stress du bruit des problèmes et
beaucoup trop de monde
alors qu'ici les seuls voisins sont les
bouquetins qui peuplent ces montagnes
regardez il y en a un là bas il y en a
plus de 15000 ce qui en fait la plus
grande concentration au monde
ici ils ont tous le climat l'altitude la
végétation c'est pour ça qu'il y en a
autant antonio et soigneur dans ce parc
naturel c'est l'un des seuls à pouvoir
approcher ces bouquetins
aujourd'hui il s'occupe d'un mâle de 3
ans qu'il a réussi à sauver à la
naissance
quand sa mère est morte j'ai dû m'en
occuper comme si c'était mon enfant et
trois ans plus tard vous voyez comme il
va bien
ici les bouquetins sont suivis
identifier et soigner afin de préserver
l'espèce un sanctuaire en plein coeur de
la montagne
[Musique]
suspendues à plus de 100 mètres de
hauteur
voici l'un des sentiers de randonnée les
plus spectaculaires au monde
huit kilomètres de courbes construites à
flanc de falaise juste au dessus de
l'eau
sur le camino del rei
sensations fortes garanties
c'est incroyable ce qui a été construit
il est choqué mais parcourir ce chemin
de randonnée se mérite avant de
commencer l'ascension quelques consignes
de sécurité à respecter
port du casque obligatoire
on garde le casque tout le temps même
s'il nourrit hier il a plu et la terre
et donc plus molle que d'habitude pour
mille dans un blâme de la normale nous
voilà parti pour deux heures de marche
en plein coeur de la montagne andalouse
et sa nature
avec très vite la drôle d'impression
d'être comme suspendu dans le vide i
want et nombreux sont ceux qui ont le
vertige il serait mieux qu'ils avancent
peuple au cas où ils sont pris par la
force
et pourtant ce chemin de randonnée a
bien évolué depuis sa construction en
1920 à l'époque il a la triste
réputation d'être le sentier le plus
dangereux au monde
voilà à quoi il ressemblait avant
rénovation
du rock c'est effectivement on veut voir
les anciens chemins ceux qui n'ont pas
été rénovés je ne les prendrai jamais on
ne peut pas passer sous celui là
sur ces images d'amateurs le surnom de
randonnée de la mort prend tout son sens
trou dans la passerelle aucune barrière
de protection au total huit personnes y
perdront la vie avant qu'il ne soit
rénové il ya quatre ans un chantier hors
du commun
et professionnels et des escaladeurs se
sont chargés de la construction de
chemins sont des hélicos peltre amenait
les matériaux nécessaires à la
rénovation
aujourd'hui parfaitement sécurisé le
caminito del rei n'en reste pas moins
surprenant
pas de quoi décourager les touristes
venus affronter leur peur du vide
qui appréhendait beaucoup et en fait ça
a été un vrai bonheur donc aucun
problème
moi j'avais peur mais c'était une super
expérience
une attraction qui attire chaque année
plus de 300000 visiteurs
[Musique]
à séville il suffit de passer cet
immense arche pour voyager dans le temps
très exactement il ya un siècle et demi
à l'époque un seul chevaux et calèches
circulent et en double
[Musique]
les feria de séville c'est le meilleur
médicament pour être toujours de bonne
humeur c'est une manière de conserver
nos traditions notre culture et nous en
sommes fiers
le temps d'une semaine les sévit en fait
les férias costumes traditionnels
musique et danse flamenco
le ton est tout de suite donné
là nous avons attendu toute l'année pour
les célébrer c'est une semaine très
intense avec beaucoup de danse de verre
de vin de rire en compagnie des amis
nous en profitons
une tradition qui n'a pas évolué depuis
sa création en 1850 ici les règles sont
très strictes robe de flamenco
obligatoire pour les femmes nous mettons
nos fleurs nos boucles d'oreilles tout
est parfait pour pouvoir dans ses
grands parents tantes cousins ici tout
le monde participe et ce dès le plus
jeune âge
effectuer une enfant tu viens avec des
fleurs et tu danses la sévillane à ta
mère tu emmènes même dans sa poussette
de quoi étonner les touristes pas
vraiment habillé pour l'occasion tous
admirent notamment ses pas de danse si
particulier les sévillanes à ce qui
s'accompagne toujours d'un air de
flamenco
si tu veux aborder une femme il faut lui
demander de danse et la sévillane avec
toi car lors d'une feria elle ne
refusera jamais et d'études ans tu
t'approches de son visage est
normalement c'est gagné
elle se danse dans la rue mais aussi
dans ces petites tapes les casetas il y
en a plus de 1000 pour l'occasion et
c'est à l'intérieur de celle-ci que la
fête suit son cours
au départ c'était un lieu de commerce et
des entrepreneurs se réunissent et avec
le temps ça s'est transformé en un lieu
festif où l'on s'amuse tous les
festivités dureront jusqu'au bout de la
nuit en attendant déjà impatiemment
l'année prochaine pour de nouveau faire
vivre la tradition des ferias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme un air de bout du monde à la
pointe sud de l'espagne au turquoise
roches volcaniques entre ces immenses
falaises se cache le dernier écrin de la
côte méditerranéenne
un espace unique de 50 kilomètres de
littoral sans aucune construction et où
la présence de l'homme est au mieux
tolérés
la zone est un peu sinueuse mais c'est
pour ça qu'il n'ya pas de tourisme de
masse ici c'est un tourisme naturel 20
mille hectares de nature et très vite
l'étrange sensation d'être seuls au
monde dans ce paysage fort mais il y a
des millions d'années
ce sont des volcans en éruption qui ont
créé la zone tout ce qu'on voit au tour
c'est de la lawe solidifier au contact
de l'eau walk and gas calme à une
succession de chemins escarpés qui de
toutes les manières vous emmèneront sur
des plages et des criques paradisiaques
ouais cool comme les philippines je suis
allé il ya deux ans mais cette fois
c'est beaucoup plus proche un vrai petit
paradis
et dans ce décor de carte postale une
poignée de pêcheurs vite encore à
l'année
très allez on va jeter dans le pays si
luis est l'un d'entre eux
ce sentiment de liberté pouvoir respirer
cet air pur plus qu'une profession pour
moi c'est une façon de vivre et pour
préserver les fonds marins ici la pêche
est artisanale les filets utilisés ne
descende 4,2 mètres de profondeur
regarde ça c'est l'un des plus beaux
poissons de la zone on l'appelle le
poisson diable à cause de ses couleurs
ce qu'il a dit qu il est magnifique
au total plus de 500 espèces de poissons
peuple la zone et pour les apercevoir
canoë kayak obligatoires allez on avance
un peu et on va s'arrêter dans ce parc
il y a six réserves maritimes et nous
allons visiter la plus belle celle du
récif des sirènes à la cristal arena à
l'intérieur une eau cristalline
il suffit d'un masque d'un tuba
et de se jeter à l'eau pour profiter du
spectacle
c'est incroyable dans cette eau limpide
et transparentes on voit la semaine
c'est magnifique et s'il fallait
un paradis perdu très loin du tourisme
de masse que les espagnols souhaitent
jalousement gardés secrets
[Musique]
au bout de cette route
le décor semble tout droit sorti d'un
monde imaginaire
perdue dans la campagne andalouse ronda
une cité médiévale construite à même la
falaise
perché à 100 mètres de hauteur
c'est un rêve pour les photographes
c'est typiquement la photo qu'on voit
ensuite dans les magazines sauf que là
c'est moi qui peux l'apprendre aux
acteurs
comme n'importe quelle montagne la perle
suspendu d'andalousie ne révèle ses
secrets cas ce qu'il a gravi rompt
avec un peu de bonne volonté on y arrive
et en plus la récompense est quand même
incroyable
la récompense la voici à 100 mètres au
dessus du vide ce balcon offre une vue
unique à ce qui bien sûr n'ont pas le
vertige
d'ici entouré par cette immensité on
sent vraiment tout petit
dc s'aperçoit aussi le symbole de ronda
ce pont du xviiie siècle relie la ville
au reste de l'espagne une prouesse
architecturale que nous fait découvrir
kilar
archéologue et maîtresse des lieux
vraiment très étroit donc attention aux
mains
elle nous emmène jusqu'aux entrailles du
monument
là où seuls quelques privilégiés peuvent
accéder
ça a été vraiment compliqué en 1733 un
premier point a été construit et six ans
après il s'est effondré il aura fallu
quarante ans et trois architectes pour
le réaliser comme d'un voyage
ce pont a longtemps servi d'aqueduc
permettant ainsi de stocker de
précieuses réserves d'eau et faisant de
ronda une oasis en plein coeur de
l'andalousie
tout cela rendue possible grâce à
l'ingéniosité des habitants au 14e
siècle toute cette roche et creusé sur
près de 60 mètres de profondeur avec
pour objectif d'acheminer l'eau du
fleuve jusqu'aux habitations une série
de dénivelé qui nous mène jusqu'aux
gorges du tage
le plus long fleuve de la péninsule
ibérique
combat la vue est encore plus
impressionnante oui et surtout quand on
imagine tout ce qui a pu se passer ici
au fil des siècles
une histoire qui a fait deux rondes à
l'un des berceaux de l'espagne
[Applaudissements]
voilà pourquoi elle abrite les plus
vieilles à rennes du pays où sont passés
les plus grands toreros
c'est le cas de raphaël aujourd'hui
éleveurs de taureaux
au xviiie siècle c'est une famille de
ronda qui a inventé la tauromachie telle
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui dans le
monde
autant de secrets qui font aujourd'hui
de ronda la deuxième ville la plus
touristique d'andalousie avec chaque
jour plus de dix mille visiteurs
comme un prolongement de ces crêtes
rocheuses l'alhambra surplombe grenade
immobile éternel
mais quelque chose a changé entre ses
murs
les files de touristes du monde entier
évanoui le brouhaha des passants disparu
les rares visiteurs savoure un moment
hors du temps
eto'o a commencé comme un cadeau de
l'avoir avec se demande
avec le
ressent mieux l'atmosphère qui doit
voulu créer ici
j'ai l'impression d'être chez moi comme
c'était ma mère loin un silence presque
troublant dans le deuxième monument le
plus visité d'espagne
si pour nous l'année passée a semblé
interminable lorsqu'on a six siècles
comme l'alhambra c'est sans doute juste
une pause une respiration
on la longeur aliciens l'argent reste
est un complément du vin comme avance la
restauration des musées la méga mêmes
l'occasion de s'offrir une seconde
jeunesse
il y à des lieux où il était très
difficile d'intervenir car il y avait
trop de touristes a comme dans cette
pièce par exemple ou pas c'est ici que
se trouvait le trône du sultan et d'où
il dirige et toutes les cérémonies au
14e siècle
pour alicia restauratrice de céramique
la précision est primordial
elle passera 15 jours sur sept colonnes
ces dvd il faut qu'on puisse voir la
différence entre ce qui a été restauré
et l'original même si le tourisme nous
manque c'est beaucoup mieux pour moi de
pouvoir travailler en silence
des trésors d'architecturé islamique que
même les rois catholiques se refuse à
détruire après la reconquête au xvème
siècle pour affirmer leur présence ils
ajoutent leurs propres fresques et
gravures dans certaines pièces comme
celle-ci patriciens temps cela aussi de
retarder les effets du temps
cette fresque colorée n'était en train
de se détacher de son support
un travail quasi chirurgicale
je passe de nombreuses heures ici alors
il m'arrive de parler au bois
je suis là pour prendre soin de toi
alors s'il te plaît
pour que le voyage dans le temps soit
totale même les légumes du potager de
l'alhambra ne sont pas choisis au hasard
la cape town artichauts et est un légume
que l'on cultivait à l'époque musulmane
et médiévale tout comme les autres
plantes que l'on retrouve dans ses
potagers d'ailleurs nous utilisons les
méthodes antique pour les cultiver des
voix et voici les gardiens inattendue de
ses jardins cet aigle et faucons pour
repousser un ennemi qui a pris ses aises
dans la citadelle
à part dans ma prison ont proliféré
encore il l'est bien moins de touristes
est là c'est devenu une oasis pause nous
on essaye de leur faire comprendre que
c'est un territoire hostile et des
rapaces que les princes arabes faisait
déjà volé en leur temps ce sont peut
être finalement les plus fidèles
protecteur de l'alhambra
comme toutes les histoires de chercheurs
d'or la nôtre commence sur un bateau ou
plutôt trois parmi les plus célèbres au
monde la pinta la niña et la santa maria
les caravelles de christophe colomb de
retour d'amérique après une odyssée de
plus de sept mois
ça devait être fou de voyager sur ces
bacs de s'en apercevoir une mouette dit
une cause juste l'horizon et se dire on
verra bien quand on arrivera en mars
1493 où l'on revient en héros à son port
de départ palos de la frontera au sud de
l'andalousie la ville conserve fièrement
les reproductions grandeur nature de ces
trois navires
au total il y avait 90 marrant
répartition les trois bateaux
attention à la tête
il valait mieux pas être trop bon figure
toi que christophe colomb était
justement de petite taille les lieux ça
c'est le gouvernail c'est ce qui
permettait de diriger le bateau
est là il faut descendre comme si
c'était une échelle
nous suivons notre guide dans les
entrailles de la caravelle
on reconnaît la forme de la poule c la
partie avant du bateau à l'abri du vent
et des vagues lakhal était à la fois le
dortoir et le garde manger de l'équipage
hélas comme vous le voyez il ya aussi
beaucoup de tonneaux c'est là qu'il
stocker l'eau tout le voyage
sur ces navires d'un autre temps les
visiteurs se rêve matelots ou capitaine
it flotte ici comme une envie d'aventuré
cette impressionnante s'imaginer que des
matelots marché sur ses planches mouillé
en pleine tempête dans l'océan
atlantique se sont tant d'efforts
nécessaires sans pourtant savoir où l'on
va servir à l'anglais
pour beaucoup de marins le voyage se
terminer à quelques pas de là derrière
cette porte
là franchir m'étais pas vraiment bon
signe
ils en ont les hommes dans la maison de
la miséricorde ils ont tenté de soigner
les maladies contre lesquelles les
européens et les colons n'étaient pas
signés comme par exemple la dengue ou la
fièvre jaune à manille à
quelques marches plus haut sylvia tient
à nous montrer le plus grand héritage de
ses premiers explorateurs
ou est ce thème un passé délit né un 17
carte du tracé après les premières
expéditions vers le nouveau monde encore
un peu nu au mont d'or en chine comment
faire mais le périple de colons mais pas
tout à fait terminé il lui faut encore
rallié séville pour livrer sa cargaison
d'or ramenées d'amérique et il doit
absolument le faire par bateau pour
comprendre pourquoi nous embarquons avec
mercedes une historienne de la région
tout le monde savait que l'on revenait
avec de l'or plein les cales emprunter
les ressources et et s'exposer à une
attaque de brigands c'était plus
dangereux que le fleuve beaucoup plus
dangereux et en plus le voyage était
bien plus l'on parle atteint damas mardi
à porter mais naviguer sur ces eaux à
l'embouchure du fleuve guadalquivir
reste une mission périlleuse mario notre
capitaine du jour on sait quelque chose
regarder on aperçoit d'ici un ancien
cargo de marchandises qui devait
apporter du riz jusqu'à 6
la légende raconte que le capitaine
utilisons un peu alcoolisé et qu'il a
échoué ils sont d'atouts sur un banc de
sable
on l'a laissé ici comme une mise en
garde pour les marins pour qu'ils se
souviennent que le guadalquivir est
encore mal près de la mer il ne faut
surtout pas baisser la garde surtout en
allant par là
avec l'arrivée des conquistadors
sanlucar de barrameda passe d'un petit
port de pêcheurs à une riche cité
marchande c'est d'ailleurs derrière les
grilles de la demeure d'une des plus
influentes familles de la ville que nous
allons admirer un héritage méconnu des
explorateurs les plantes exotiques
les églises et les familles nobles ont
été les premières à créer des jardins
avec les plantes que les explorateurs
ramenait du nouveau monde domine celle
ci par exemple elle est tout à fait
commune en europe maintenant est un mais
elle vient d'amérique latine
ont les étudiait pour essayer d'en faire
des médicaments
nous quittons la ville et ses jardins en
longeant le guadalquivir cap vers le
nord
[Musique]
nous entrons dans une vaste zone
marécageuse entièrement dédié à la
culture du riz la isla minima c'est ici
dans ces paysages gorgée d'eau et sous
un soleil accablant que nous rencontrons
tony et ses mille cinq cents brebis
fraîchement tondues
elles sont pleines transhumance donc
devant qui s'est étendue plate pour
aller au delà des montagnes
gâteau il faudra marché de nuit quand
les chaleurs sur une trop forte on
pourra plus le père de 1,6 en andalousie
il
espérait
notre route s'est faite chemin de
poussière les kilomètres défilent et
nous avons un problème il nous faut
passer sur l'autre rive mais aucun pont
à l'horizon seule solution monter à bord
de cette drôle d'embarcation
[Musique]
bonjour bien cette moto prend 0,20 ou qe
3 1
vient deux fois par jour on les compte
même plus on n'arrête pas de 6 heures du
matin à 22 heures 30 plus de 150
véhicules traversent ainsi chaque jour
deux fleuves et certains plus encombrant
que d'autres j'ai des champs de part et
d'autre du fleuve essence bâton je
mettrais 2h30 pour aller d'un champ à
l'autre et avec le bateau
seulement 30 minutes
il n'y a aucun pont jusqu'à sévit pour
pouvoir laisser passer les bateaux donc
tant qu ils ne construisent pas un
tunnel sous le fleuve on peut gagner
notre pain comme ça
[Musique]
nous voilà donc du bon côté du fleuve
pour rejoindre notre prochaine étape
[Musique]
une ferme gigantesque et majestueuse
dans le plus pur style andalou niché sur
les bords du guadalquivir
pour moi c'est une passion depuis
toujours petit j'étais au milieu des
choix je le serai jusqu à la fin
[Musique]
l'huile est de pure race andalouse le
sel du fleuve lui apporte beaucoup de
minéraux et on fait un cheval robuste
un décor grandiose qui a attiré les
caméras de cinéma pour le tournage d'un
film bien connue des français
c'est ici qu'est essaie de tourner une
scène de la folie des grandeurs avec
louis de funès la production n'avait pas
de budget pour louer la ferme alors ils
ont proposé de la repeindre
intégralement
très près de l'embouchure du fleuve les
embruns salés attaquent en permanence
les peintures
le guadalquivir tour à tour adversaires
et allié des andalous il est toujours
utilisé pour le transport de
marchandises et nous imaginons tout à
coup les caravelles qu'il naviguait
autrefois chargé d'or jusqu'à ces villes
comme elle nous remontons les 50
derniers kilomètres qui nous séparent de
la capitale andalouse pour terminer
notre voyage nous avons rendez vous sur
les quais à un endroit bien précis
nous sommes en face de la tour dorée
c'est ici qu'ils étaient stockés lors
apportées par les explorateurs c'était
le point final d'absolument chaque
bateau qui revenait d'amérique imaginez
l'emportait ce de celle tôt c'était l'un
des bâtiments les plus surveillées du
pays ne fait pas la taille est vraiment
pourri marina une route de l'or qui a
enrichi une ville et toute sa région
dans le sillage d'aventuriers à la
recherche de la gloire éternelle